every summer the park around the sanct
emmagan palace becomes an exclusive
picnic site and the royal residence of
tone on taxes becomes a venue for
musicians of all styles Princess Gloria
phone tone on taxes has of course
invited all her relatives to lagan spoke
for her big open-air event my job is is
even as the hostess it's my job to
entertain my friends to be present
cheerful and happy at all times this is
a 14-day shinda a non-stop garden party
and meeting with the artists is a lot of
fun Don Martha's miss pass activa
gignoux meeting goons lon
artists like Max haba it's his third
time here performing songs from the
1920s and 30s with his ensemble the
Palast Acosta
via via written would we only perform
where we want to where the atmosphere is
good and it's fun to play in thumbs loss
behind the palace in this beautiful park
you could play forever was he starting
and I must say these are the best
dressing rooms we've ever had on tour
that hadn't even German pop king udo
jürgens feels at home here in the palace
courtyard that's hot I've never seen an
audience like this before yo gan's is
one of the most successful musicians in
the world he sold more than 100 million
records in the last 50 years but
performing here is still something
special I mentioned in Abood ability a
person who performs onstage always has a
lot of respect for the people who come
and listen for big enough alpha
dimension at the into an or and the
audience also shows so much respect for
what we're doing that's really something
special for us so what sue Martin is
photography and VA deacons lizette
represent us at intermission visitors
use the time to chat over a glass of
champagne or enjoy some fine food
the princess also mingles with the crowd
she loves sharing her world with others
they think about you just enjoy the
place when she get to be in these
surroundings people get closer to her
because she opens the palace up to the
people neyo the kamati mention Allianz
you can see it's rare for a person to
successfully unify tradition with such
openness she's so charming and cheeky I
just love the cheekiness of course yer
ghans had the princess in mind when
choosing his tunes for the evening
East arbiter Phillips aledo so I think
many songs sir I know she likes music
and she'll be moved emotionally touched
by some of the songs in the repertoire
via the CPR inlets in l if you invert
this evening udo jürgens won the hearts
of all the guests to ask them on was but
it's just brilliant the way he grabs the
audience in a snap sensational and then
the songs are so wonderful yet
reflective as well who knows Oh pshaw
that will do you tan with food organs as
one of the old school creamy yogurt and
the M akan palace it's the highlight for
Hagen's board this year him off she does
it so well praise for our princess after
the concert the princess invited Udo
Young's to join the audience in dining
in the palace grounds a meal that even
one of Germany's top celebrities wasn't
about to miss